[Musique]
tolstoï ou dostoïevski un essai de
george steiner georges stener est
américain il enseigne actuellement à
l'université britannique de cambridge
george steiner vous écrivez dans votre
livre et c'est même la phrase choc qui
apparaît sur la bande du livre vous
écrivez demandé à un homme s'il préfère
tolstoï dostoïevski vous connaîtrez le
secret de son coeur pourquoi faire de
tolstoï et dostoïevski
ces cas limites en quelque sorte ce
qu'atteste il est des oeuvres d'art qui
nous force en quelque sorte à choisir
parce qu elle vous prennent à la gorge
pour ainsi dire et elles disent voilà
une vision du monde de dieu de votre
rôle dans le monde
choisissez entre nous nous avons des
visions opposées antagonistes et pour
moi ce sont là les deux géants du roman
qui est après tout la forme
contemporaine par excellence la forme
qui a succédé au poème épique au drame
tragique nous sommes dans le siècle si
vous voulez vous dans le second siècle
du roman et ce sont les deux grands
maîtres de cette forme et quoi que nous
puissions les apprécier tous deux je
crois que chaque homme en soit choisi
l'un plutôt que l'autre c'est à dire
disons 'peut-être pour simplifier les
choses le rationalisme
et puis d'autre part l'irrationnel
dostoïevski en sommet pour simplifier
dit au monde entier si vous voulez le
royaume de la justice sur terre le
royaume de la raison vous aboutissez par
la ruine par l'inhumain par le monde
concentrationnaire qu'il a prévus dans
les possédés dry karamazov et tolstoï
dit non c'est ici qu'il faut bâtir le
royaume de l'homme et de dieu et si vous
et vous esquivez en pensant au ciel au
transcendant alors vous aboutirez par
l'injustice et les deux solutions sont
antagonistes et très ennemis elle ne
s'arrête pas également toutes deux et je
crois d'instinct de raison de
sensibilité ne choisissons pourquoi le
plus précisément avoir choisi deux
russes parce que je crois que dans le
roman
ce sont les géants les géants qui
définissent les limites même de cette
forme il y a eu trois très grand moment
dans notre littérature
le moment grecque les tragiques grecs le
moment shakespearien une roman restée
moment d'ailleurs très bref curieusement
bref j'espère entre les débuts de gogol
et la fin de tolstoï 60 ans 60
fulgurante avec des chefs-d'oeuvre
presque tout les ans tous les ans comme
sous shakespeare et 10 ou 12 très grands
contemporains ce sont ces moments des
moments de crise d'habitude la proche de
révolution ou de chutes de civilisation
ou la littérature semble porter cette
charge d'angoise de révolution les
grandes questions que la philosophie
pose d'une façon abstraite lviv dans le
mode littéraire et tolstoï et
dostoïevski ont montré que le roman peut
tenir tête à sophocle aïchi la
shakespeare oui mais tout de même nous
avons tendance à croire que le roman le
grand roman est né et a vécu aussi
ailleurs qu'en russie en france par
exemple
le roman français a pris la décision
d'être entièrement un grand roman
séculier c'est à dire que lorsque balzac
cresson monde génial c'est le monde de
la bourgeoisie du paysan c'est ce monde
sans dieu il effleure le problème de
dieu mais dans le très mauvais livres
dans séraphine tas dans le christ en
flandre chez proust il y à leur fut un
refus de génie si vous voulez mais
d'ouvrir les portes vers le ciel ou
l'enfer
imaginez mitia karamazov en chaussettes
avec dieu au plafond hurlant avec son
âme ça ne va pas dans proust ni les
chaussettes sales par iliad impose de la
saleté mais jamais du mauvais goût ni
dieu et pour simplifier naïvement les
chaussettes sales et la présence de dieu
vont ensemble elles vont ensemble en
shakespeare elles vont ensemble paraît
grand poème épique et aussi dans le
roman russe il est remarquable que le
roman français est produit madame bovary
tolstoï répond par anna karénine le
roman français produit le rouge le noir
où la chartreuse de parme avec leurs
politiques et leurs napoléon dans le sto
et répond par guerre et paix et d'os tf
qui par les possédés et
est ce que vous pensez du roman français
actuel eh bien il est presque
l'aboutissement
de ce triomphe du style de l'autonomie
de la cadence et du langage sur le
contenu humain je vois bientôt que le
roman français va nous présenter des
oeuvres ou des chats et chaises et des
tables vont parler entre elles et puis
le dernier grand roman français goristes
de cette vague du nouveau roman ce sera
un roman à feuilles blanches ça doit
venir ça débuté par mallarmé qui est le
maître du roman français actuel et à la
fin ça sur un silence le silence peut
être très beau silence si vous voulez
sur vos papiers c'est le point de vue
des américains vous nous donnez là qu'à
vous êtes américains oui mais et point
de vue j'espère d'un américain éduqué en
france qui doit à la france qu'il a
lui-même de culture littéraire
non j'espère point de vue d'un homme qui
lit et y croient qu'il est un espèce de
très hautes frivolité le très bel
formellement très intéressante mais
frivolité unis mènent à vider le roman
de la voix humaine de la présence du
corps humain qui après tout sont la base
du langage ne sommes pas en train de
faire de la musique ne sommes pas en
train de faire du pôle clé de l'art
abstrait nous travaillons avec les mots
et les mots existent dans la voix
humaine et c'est ce que tolstoï
dostoïevski n'oublie jamais même quand
ils prennent le risque du mauvais goût
des longueurs du ridicule du grotesque
mais ils prennent ces grands risques et
c'est ce qui manque dans ces petits
livres main c'est parfait qu'on nous
offre maintenant car après tout entre un
livre très gros et un livre mince la
différence est presque d'ordre
métaphysique non seulement technique le
livre très mince c'est toujours la
princesse de clèves ça se refuse à la
vie avec intelligence harthouse que vous
voulez mais il ya là un certain revue
parce que la vie n'est pas un livre
mince elle est terriblement longue et
touffue et danse et tolstoï ne voulait
même pas arrêter guerre et paix 2
épilogue huit chapitres nouveau c'était
comme le temps lui-même en marche et
dossier explique écrit ses livres
gigantesque précisément parce qu'il veut
toujours recommencée leurrer souvenons
nous que les frères karamazov c'est le
premier volume d'un cycle qu'il n'a pas
pu écrire il est mort et bien je vous
remercie georges stener et je rappelle
que votre livre tolstoï et dostoïevski
après avoir paru aux états unis en
angleterre et dans quelques autres pays
paraît en france aux éditions du seuil
dans la traduction de rose saisis
[Musique]